this clip might be a little bit
uncomfortable because I knew Shane
Gillis was going to hate this question
and I asked him anyway but it is Juicy
and it's brought to you by athletic
greens so stick around at the end for a
killer deal from them yeah dude Mark
Normand we've even we were talking to
him about how you were
coming on and he said that that you you
see set up be careful dude and Shane
does not like uh people suggesting that
uh that the cancel culture worked in
history oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
I I thought that that was kind of
interesting because I had
suggest and and apologies here for going
ahead and saying exactly oh no they
don't want to hear I get it but uh yeah
I get it yeah all right I just think
it's I just think it's fascinating but
like my question was like is it it's
safe to to assume that there there have
been plenty of people who were bona fide
cast members on Saturday and Night Live
and just pretty quiet about it sure you
know I like to really take off they were
just sort of like you know
um some people became big stars and and
a lot of people didn't and uh
for you like it but it was kind of a
launching deal like it was just like
everything yeah everybody it got eyes on
me for sure so there's that like I what
I what I've talked to Mark about is like
how it's annoying when like comedians
will be like I think it helped you and
it's like right bro
like maybe maybe but it might have
helped if I didn't get canceled and I
was on SNL like that could have been
good right
that could have been maybe I could have
been good on there
um yeah but were you because you had to
probably work [ __ ] 10 times harder to
get that's the other thing is it's the
ego part of it where it's like no it's
not like I was just handed this yeah
getting canceled isn't a good thing
unless you do well afterwards yeah you
know what I mean and then it I don't
like to ever be in that position where I
gotta be like no I'm good like you know
what I mean I don't want to right let me
move on from that yeah whatever
apologies for again saying precisely
here he's like now he also said he
didn't want to talk about your mother
how's she doing yeah she's still dead
but now he said that uh he said that
you've got a new sketch show oh yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] unbelievable uh we
just released it like an hour ago the oh
trailer for it it's going to come out
October 4th so this is yeah it'll be up
so Gillian keeves dot TV and if you go
to athletic greens.com Stevo they're
gonna give you five free travel packs
with your comprehensive convenient daily
nutrition for the day five of them plus
an entire year's supply of immune
boosting vitamin D that's the deal for
the Wild Ride listeners if you go to
athleticgreens.com
slash Stevo you get that with your first
order yeah